- [Voiceover] Let's talk about your hair.
- My hair.
- [Voiceover] We're not
washing our hair for a week.
(laughing)
- Ah--
- [Daysha] I'm crying.
- [Voiceover] Why are we doing this?
What is--
- Why are we doing this?
(laughing)
(upbeat, quirky music)
I basically don't shampoo
my hair most times already,
so, I think I'm good on this challenge.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I think we're good.
- [Voiceover] Great, great.
- [Voiceover] Cut.
- Apparently if you don't wash your hair
some people say that their
hair is like better moisturized
or, you know, it looks shinier, maybe,
because sometimes shampoos
can be sort of harsh
and they can dry out your hair.
- [Voiceover] Do you have
any social obligations
that you're concerned about?
- Yeah, I have some
social obligations here.
I mean, one, being a
normal human, that's out.
Two, I just flicked off
the camera (laughs).
- I'm afraid my hair's gonna
get real greasy and gross.
- I think I'm going to
to be looking pretty ugly
come like tomorrow, Friday, Saturday,
like it's gonna be interesting.
- It's day two of no shampooing.
I think my hair looks crazy.
- This is day three of not washing my hair
and yeah, there it is.
It just feels bad,
like when I lay on a pillow.
- I'm at the beach, it's a beautiful day.
After this my hair is
just gonna be disgusting.
I honestly don't know
if I'm gonna make it.
- Looks real flat in the back.
I think people could see
that maybe I've got a real flat head.
- I look like a god(bleep) candle.
I imagine it doesn't
smell that great either.
(sniffing)
I don't like it.
- Yeah, it doesn't smell good.
- Oh, (bleep) that is pungent.
- Look how greasy it looks,
like it looks wet.
- Mine's not as greasy
as I thought it would be.
- All I wanna do is use some dry shampoo.
Why are you doing this to me?
This was really, really hard. (laughs)
- My hair doesn't smell as
much as I thought it would
but it's not pleasant.
- It smells like (bleep).
- The first couple days
of not washing my hair
I actually kind of liked.
But, as the week went on,
it was just chaos.
- I just feel disgusting.
My hair looks like it's wet
even though it's not.
- Every morning I woke up
with a weird hairstyle.
- I think maybe if I'd done
it for longer than a week
my body would have figured
out what was going on
and tried to naturally
compensate or something.
But after a week, it's just trash.
A big pile of trash up here.
So, you know, I don't recommend it.
(upbeat, twinkling music)
(ethereal vocal tones)